OK, I got a very, very important question
via voicemail.
This is a practical question about long voting
lines for November.
Take a listen to this.
Very important to know the answer.
David, I just have a question.
Is it true that if you are in line to vote
on voting day or on Election Day, that you
have to legally be allowed to vote?
So.
You know, even if the line is two hours long,
it's Margaret.
You're standing in it before the polls close.
Are you legally able to vote?
That's what I'm wondering about.
Thank you.
OK.
Very important question.
Legally speaking, if you are in line to vote,
by the time the polls close, you must be legally
allowed to vote.
The way it's supposed to work is if polls
close at eight o'clock at eight o'clock, someone,
a poll worker is supposed to go to the end
of the line and sort of be a placeholder for
the end of the line if you are in front of
the poll worker.
You must be allowed to vote whether it takes
five minutes or five hours or five days because
you were in line while the polls were open.
That's the rule.
You have to get to the polls before they close.
If you try to get in line after the polls
have closed, the poll worker would say this
is the end of the line.
The polls are now closed.
You're not going to be allowed to vote.
That's the way it's supposed to work.
You can weaponize that.
You could hypothetically, if you were a bad
actor, you could try to disproportionately
send people to try to spread disinformation
and usher people in line away by saying the
polls have already closed.
You're not going to be allowed to vote.
You could focus that effort in Democratic
precincts, for example, where you're not looking
specifically at who's in line, but you're
like, okay, this precinct has more Democrats,
this precinct has more Republicans.
Let's go to the Democratic precinct and try
to get people to go home and say the polls
have closed.
You're not going to be allowed to vote.
You could do that.
And so the point is, yes, if you're in line
before the polls close, you must be allowed
to vote.
There may be dirty tricks.
They may poll stuff.
Don't fall for it.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
A Florida sheriff is telling his deputies
not to wear masks.
If you can imagine a woman who says she has
corona virus is being evicted.
And we have new polling from the Senate race
in Massachusetts between incumbent Ed Markey
and challenger Joe Kennedy.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.